very ironic that the zionists thought
that they could use that video that
Drone footage to make it look like they
won when in fact it just inspired so
many people show their
arrogance did you guys know the
definition of emergency is a serious
situation that requires immediate action
imagine your loved ones under Rubble in
earthquake or bombs being dropped in
Gaza or in Yemen or in Afghanistan where
there's an earthquake brother and sister
we're working with one om to get
immediate relief to those who are in
need please go to the link and don't
whatever you can in and let this be a
that you was for your you was there for
your brothers and sisters when they
need brothers and sisters and dear
friends I don't know about you guys but
I was taken back and quite surprised I
just kind of checked Twitter for news
and all that kind of stuff I'm not
really that active on there but I was
surprised and actually shocked at the
response of Muslims of course but
non-muslims reaction to the death and
obviously for many the them of y sin
we're just going to watch it in because
there was some so many people I just
wrote his name on Twitter on X and
here's the reaction obviously the first
one is of um sneo let's see what he had
to say inshah rest in peace and may
Allah Grant Yaya the highest rank in Jan
inshah that was the most inspiring story
that I've heard I think in my whole life
seeing what happened to Yaya sinir very
ironic that the Zionist thought that
they could use that video that Drone
footage to make it look like they won
when in fact it just inspired so many
people people show their arrogance to
show a true hero like that fighting on
the front lines it's the last breath
with a wire wrapped around his arm
throwing something at the Drone coming
after him look how visually
representative that is of the situation
tanks drones snipers all against one man
in his Spirit a man in his stick they
need all that to take out one 63y old
man born in a refuge Camp 25 years in
prison being tortured and still they
could not break his Spirit until the
last final breath that's what shows the
power that was nio he's a Muslim of
course but scrolling down a bit you've
got people like Jackson Hingle y s when
we are killed for the sake of God we do
not die so uh he's been talking about it
somebody wrote a single hair camil a
single hair on yah's head is more honor
has more honor and dignity than the
entire of the western world uh we've got
a Chinese individual MinGa yah sin is
not only a hero for Palestinian
yah is also a hero to all the to all
those who resist Anglo-Saxon imperialism
and Jewish supremacism worldwide China
salutes comrade Yahya Sinar Andre Tate
who's a Muslim I can only pray for a
death as heroic as Yahya Sinar Brave
defined in the face of evil and
dedicated to his life purpose he
deserves Eternal rest he earned it Dan
Cohan sounds like a Jewish name but I
don't know I want to judge Israel made
the biggest mistake of publishing
footage of yah last moment wearing a c
CA and severely injured in in severely
injured he threw a stick at the Drone uh
filming him in a final Act of defiance
against the Z's occupation in his death
he has become a legend Shan pedri mcari
Israel promised some of the poorest
people on the Earth
$400,000 and a chance to escape death if
they betrayed yah sin and none of them
would do it over here in the richest
country on Earth people stay silent
about the genocide genocide to protect
their act acting careers what a contrast
somebody called Hadi saying isra Israel
accidentally turned Yahya as to an in to
an into an international hero The Man
became a legend someone called Keith
Woods incredible footage Yahya Sinar
covered in dust all his comrades just
killed arm amputated and close to death
HS a project projectile at an Israeli
drone in a file Act of defiance I mean
isn't it crazy guys I'm going to read
more there's more of this coming there's
someone called khes she seems like a
non-muslim I don't know Israel released
morage of y's final moments he's wounded
and immobilized as an Israeli tank Fires
at him it took a drone a tank and an
aerial bombing to kill one man thereby
commenting the legendary status afforded
to him he will be seen as an icon always
it is unbelievable the amount of
non-muslims on X and everywhere for that
matter who are seeing this as an
absolute Act of defiance yes so this is
just is quite surprising and like
shocking because the way Allah subh T
works but it's like it's crazy and
Subhan Allah you look at these people
from Muslims to non-muslims it just
seems like the Zionist propaganda
because zionists have got their hands
everywhere in the media it just doesn't
work it is not working the tide has
changed the anti-Semitism card is not
working Zionism efforts are not working
pumping Millions if not billions of
pounds which they have been doing to
fund people like the far right to hate
on Islam Islam and spread false
information about Islam is not working
they are on their way out the whole
entire globe and one one PA Network an
amazing video and analyzing how Israel
the zionists are losing this battle on
every single font it's not working
whatever they're doing taking out
leaders it's not working because the
funny thing about this is yahar made a
video which you can see for yourself
saying that he would rather die as a mar
on the battlefield then die from covid
or something like that for that matter
now myself looking from objectively
without taking anybody's side if I was a
non-muslim I'm looking at this I'll be
like my gosh my support my support for
the Palestinians for the resistance
would amplify I'll like this is
unbelievable it is not working they
released that footage thinking that this
is going to be like D no it is just not
working it's just backfiring more and
backfiring more and backfiring more and
it is just carrying on so subh Allah
brother sisters I want to share a verse
from the Quran with you guys in in and I
want to end on this note because it's so
profound and Powerful for us all to
understand that when we think about a
lot of us do not see from this
perspective because I was going bit
pondering and if you think about it is
actually graduation day for the
Believers for the Believers it's a
graduation day why because that is the
day where the people that oppressed
laughed mocked killed massacred and done
many other atrocities to Muslims around
the world if you see one pattern you see
that it is always Muslims who are around
the world who have been persecuted and
no muslim armies have ever you would
ever see it is not from our religion to
ever go and commit genocide you will
never see this in history yes never ever
you see in history you see fractions of
groups and individuals pretend claiming
to be Muslim or whatever with that
matter doing atrocities who are well
misguided but you never see it on this
level where State a Muslim empire
Khalifa a rulership saying you can go
and wipe out men women and children and
we are supposed to be the terrorist
Allah says
[Music]
in and when they saw the faithful they
would say these people are truly astray
even though they were not as gay G as
Keepers over the Believers but on that
day the Believers will be laughing at
the disbelievers and they sit and they
will sit on couches looking on at them
and they will say the Believers will be
asked have the disbelievers being paid
back for what they used to do that is a
day of graduation for the Believers that
is the day and it it will only be
meaningful on that day when the
oppression and it's only in Allah's
hekma and wisdom that all this
oppression you see that going you don't
make sense of it on the day of judgment
everything is going to make sense you're
going to understand why it all happened
cuz on that day you have to see ugly to
know what is beautiful on that day the
Believers will rejoice and will see that
this Believers and we're talking about
the Hostile ones okay and those who
genuinely knew The Message of Islam is
true and rejected we're talking about
those individuals yeah let's not put all
them in the same category they will be
the Believers will say have they been
paid back for what they used to do and
they will be on reclining chairs and
they will certainly see so bear patient
Muslims because that day will come and
that day of uh graduation every Muslim
inshallah will be granted Jenna and
those who did not hear the message of
Islam God Almighty will give them a
chance to enter Paradise because our
religion is just and for those
non-muslims and Muslims around the world
may Allah subhana wa tala guide and
bless you all for supporting this c
inshallah one day Palestine is going to
be free we are going to see it and I
hope that I live to see it